can I help you
y-yes yes you can I'm here to report a
terrible crime and what terrible crime
is that this one congratulations on the
film guys Thank You Margot you worked
your ass off to get this made so why did
you want Harlee to tell her own story in
her own way
I really had a you know personal craving
to work with more actresses I really
wanted to see a go gang reflected on the
screen since I feel like I've always
been part of the girl gang since I was
four years old sort of thing with my
school friends or my American friends
and my London friends we always roll in
a gang and I just never see that on
screen and so I felt like there was a
gap in the market from a business point
of view I thought it would be a smart
endeavor and from a personal point of
view I just wanted that and I felt like
Halle actually kind of is the girls go
and she's definitely a people person
watching Halle on iron would be like
watching a kid playing a playground on
the road it's never gonna be as fun if
it's not populated with other people so
I wanted that I thought it'd be great
for the character and I thought the
industry needed a go gang action film I
couldn't agree more
now that we have Harley's story would
you want to partner up with Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker I feel like they exist
in two different worlds I feel like I
love I mean I'm fascinated by the world
that Todd Phillips and Joaquin created
but it's definitely a more grounded
reality in Oz there's a lot of grounded
elements there's a lot of grit and grime
but it's also very heightened and it
reflects Holly's personality in a lot of
ways it's colorful it's visceral it is
violent it's very funny it jumps around
it's nonlinear it's a little kooky just
like her but it's always heightened
there is that separation that
distinction from reality when it comes
to comes to our world so I don't know
how they would fit in the same in the
same yeah the same version of Gotham
yeah have you guys talked about it at
all no no yeah I wanted to ask Ellen
Chris would you guys want to see your
characters get their own spin-off movie
I know Cassandra becomes Batgirl in the
comics so what would you want her to
explore and like a spin-off Batgirl
movie
I don't know there's there's so much
more to explore with her and in the
comics how she's with Gordon and Batman
but I I would I would want to see where
it takes off because I mean when I first
found out that I got the role I I
researched so much about Cassandra Cain
and her backstory and I feel like there
definitely could be more to tell about
her story which is super exciting it I
mean there's so much to pull from with
the DC Comics and what about for you
crazy hair character
yeah you know zazz is low in the Canon
of villains in DC so I felt like a real
responsibility to kind of tread it you
know give him a voice there have been
others as there was as as and one of the
Nolan movies he'd like passes by and
Anthony Kerrigan you know that actor
from Barrie
he did it on Gotham he was fantastic but
sure there's so much more I loved
playing this character it's fun to play
a villain there's is no wrong or right
so yeah I'd love him because he has a
very specific moral code I feel like I
mean a villain who really truly thinks
he's doing the right thing yeah in the
most and obviously to everyone else is
completely sadistic and horrific but
yeah I feel like I I wish he had more
yeah as a prophet you know he's like in
his way he's like I'm saving helping
looking one face at a time yeah I
remember one of the notes was when we
were still like putting the edit
together I would remember one of them
they're like there's one too many face
looks like we look back my leg yeah
we've got three face she was incredible
with that I would do some really weird
stuff to her one particular scene and
then I went up to her after like three
or four takes and I was like it's okay
and she was like the weirder the better
I was like whenever Chris had come along
as I was like he's gonna do something so
weird I can't wait
hey you guys killed it I can't wait for
people to see this movie I'm also super
stoked for the Suicide Squad I
it's early to talk about it but Margo
can you tell us like anything about that
film not so much but I can tell you that
it's gonna be incredible and again it's
just interesting to see what a different
filmmaker makes of Gotham in these
characters and-and-and Holly really I'm
fascinated by what James finds
interesting about her compared to what
Kathy finds interesting compared to what
David found interesting about her so and
he's such a comic book lover so you know
it's always gonna be
again rooted in the source material
which is always important to me we're
gonna have to work together sure working
with Cathy and Christina influence how
you played your characters in this film
it was hugely influential you know I
spent a lot of time speaking with Cathy
about how huntresses backstory would
manifest in her personality and how that
would come out and she meets the other
women and and you know getting to play
around and improv and work off of that
but in the script there was already so
much there in terms of what was taken
from that from the comics but also all
these new sort of personality traits
that were peppered in so it was really
was a lot of fun I would concur and and
especially in the script for Renee
Montoya's character you know having to
convince the captain who took her
position that she's right about romance
Ionis you know is it's very it was very
rich for me to dive into as well so it
was really cool yeah you know um ditto
and for me the research really started
with the comic books as it did with all
of us and the conversations with Cathy
for Black Canary you know was definitely
centered around her trying to really
hone in on her origin story because in
the comic books black Canary's been
retconned quite a few times and so we
really picked and chose from different
comics in order to create the Dinah
Lance that we have in the film still
trying to do justice and maintain the
essence of Dinah Lance but really honing
in on this mother-daughter split you
know this loss that she had with
her mother who was a crime fighter and
what is that like when your mother is so
great at something like that and why why
do you choose to reject that is it
because of the trauma is it because
you're actually afraid that you could
become greater than her because you have
powers she didn't have and so those were
the motivations into the character and
really choosing in really deciding whoa
these are the choices she would make
this is why she works at black mask club
because she is trying to really go
against what her mother did she's trying
to erase her mother from her life you
know and so it was great it was great to
work with them the source material will
work with Kathy and Christina it's
awesome I mean you guys killed it we got
to talk about these action scenes they
are so unreal I know chads2 house key
was second unit director on this film
what was it like filming those scenes
and do you guys like have a favorite
moment from the fighting scene
no listen Chad's team 8711
they are some of the best in the
business and the we trained for over
five months with them in this like crazy
warehouse that no one no one we were
like hidden no one knew we were there
and and they pushed us really hard but I
think for each of our characters we're
each capable of fighting like machines
and so it's really important in order to
do justice to your character and step
into your character and or you got to
learn the physicality like I can't play
black and Aryan phone it in and be like
oh I'll let her do it you know it's like
you've got to get in the thick of it it
was inspiring to work with you all -
because y'all killed it it was great it
was inspiring I mean just to see these
women working so hard and pushing
themselves every day and there were days
when we would the way we shot the fight
scenes was often in these long runners
which means you're not doing any edits
you're just doing the whole fight from
beginning to end so we had days days on
end when we were doing nothing but
fighting and fighting and fighting and
killing ourselves and then looking at
each other be like okay here we go
hour 10 we're doing
again and they were just endlessly
inspiring just to see their tenacity and
their willingness to like go for it and
be aggressive and get dirty and I loved
it and then we had a lot of rage to get
out yeah
cathartic this woman here though is a
force I was I was gonna say that my
first day of training I tore my meniscus
disc and so it was it was I thought oh
that's it I'm gonna be out of this film
and I want to give so much credit to
8711 cuz they said oh no no we got you
we're gonna get you stronger and you're
gonna be ready come shoot time and they
did and it was pretty pretty amazing and
then inside there while I'm doing you
know calisthenics and strength training
I'm watching these two girls just I mean
just kill themselves and just end it and
it inspired me it really did inspire me
to like work that much harder
Kathy you have just made history first
Asian woman to direct a superhero film
second woman to direct a DC film after
patty Jenkins I was reading that you
actually called her while you were
prepping for this film so I wanted to
ask you how does this all feel and how
was that phone call with patty oh it was
so great
she was just lovely of course and you
know the we there aren't that many of us
that have done it so I think it
immediately created a sense you know
it's such a strong bond and a
camaraderie there and now it's just it's
it just feels good to have it out there
we've been working on it for so long
everyone worked on it really really like
such hard work there everyone was so
committed to this movie
Margo you know pitched this movie almost
five years ago now and so I think it's
just nice to have it out there I was so
excited for you did you ask patty for
any advice yeah I mean I was just like
how how do you do all this and and how
do you find the confidence to to direct
such a big thing even if you got the job
like but dad how do you actually you
know do it and you know and she was
really really kind about that and she
was like you have to just be confident
in the fact that you are the director
and that is one position that is
designed a certain way in which you you
know you get to be the center of the
decision-making the creative decision
making process for this movie and there
is no one else but you to do that so
just trust in that I love this so much
it's so colorful I was thinking about
how we've only really gotten to see
Gotham visually through I feel like
Joker and Batman's eyes so how did you
approach creating Gotham through
Harley's eyes totally well I think
Harley is both very very whimsical and
loves color and glitter and all of that
but at the same time you know there is
still very like there's a darkness to
her and a very sort of practical
grittiness to her and so that was what
we were trying to capture too
and it was we wanted to create a Gotham
that was loud and rambunctious and on
the streets and you know very diverse
and full of color and full of textures
and it had a grits and aware and terror
to it but not to the point that it was
like just completely depressing and
bleak yeah yeah you can tell it's almost
like it's shot in like the outer
boroughs mm with me um Hartley's also
very complex characters what was the
most important part of her story that
you wanted to bring to the table oh
that's a good question I think for me it
was like seeing the human vulnerable
side of Harley you know that like she
she is sort of in this like unwieldy
place after the breakup and she thinks
she can do it on her own but she kind of
can't and she she becomes extremely
vulnerable and sort of the target and
and her past very much comes back to
haunt her and I think you really get to
see all these different sides of her
where she might not have let her
emotions or her vulnerability out before
and then she's kind of you know forced
to and I think that's nice I think
that's a way to just empathize and
understand a character even more yeah
she's totally like a girl's girl in a
way to Margo was just saying that yeah
yeah the action scene I mean unreal I
know you worked with chads2 husky what
did he bring to the table for this
project sure I mean he helped us with
some of the reshoots and like he is just
he's you know he's a really he's an
amazing action director and an amazing
director in his own right with a John
wick stuff and he's just like he's a
master of that he's a master of craft
he's like so figured out exactly how to
shoot action in a very specific way and
so it was really interesting to work
with him in that in that way and learn
from him really I am personally so
fascinated by your story I know you were
a journalist and now you're like this
incredible director what advice do you
have to young women or women of all ages
they want to get into directing sure I
think believe in yourself do it like it
took me a long time to believe in myself
and so maybe save a few years of your
life
yeah really just believe in yourself and
also like believe in other women too and
help each other out because it's not
it's not a zero-sum game yeah vengeance
rarely brings the catharsis we hope for
yeah
are we ready you know what was your
process like in finding Hartley's voice
for this movie a fun one I met with
Marga about four and a half years ago
she was obviously deep in Harley right
then she was still filming Suicide Squad
and I knew Harley a little bit but it
was only kind of through getting to know
Margo we did a trip to the DC library
took a whole stack of comics and
honestly I just fell in love very hard
very fast I loved Harley in it it became
very natural it became like a language
that we became fluent in what was it
like collaborating with Margo and did
you get to work with Cathy too yeah what
I mean working with Margo was a dream
and it's been a long time and it's been
so fun she is the best creative partner
you could dream of she really puts her
heart and soul into everything we worked
very hard on this for a long time but it
was great because we've really got to
take the script to a place that we were
excited about we went through you know
different iterations different tones
different things
weirdly what's interesting is we came
all the way back around to the beginning
like the movie that it is in the end
actually feels very much like where we
began and yeah we met Cathy about just
about two years ago and it was great
getting this kind of new fresh input on
on the thing and bringing it little
pieces to life in new ways yeah it's
been it's been a dreamy experience
honestly I it was recently announced
that you were working on a Batgirl
screenplay I know it's really good you
know but what can you tell us about it
basically nothing one little nugget I
mean I can tell you that I'm working on
back out and I'm working on flash and I
will stay in the DC universe as long as
they all have me I'm I'm having the time
of my life
each of the three movies are very
different there's a very different tone
and a very different feel there's such
distinct and different characters but
I'm enjoying kind of having a finger in
each of the Vice so when I left this
film I was craving a breakfast sandwich
hahaha I need to know how the idea of
this egg sandwich came to be I liked
must know you know I really should try
and remember this I don't know I'm
food obsessive and basically all of the
early meetings of Margo we bonded over
food we ate a lot in our very first
meeting every time she would come to my
house I would make us some kind of
different delicious something yes right
when you're hungover nothing is more
important than a breakfast sandwich and
I lived in New York for a while so that
kind of dirty runny egg yolk two-dollar
egg sandwich deep in my heart you can't
get it anywhere else no walk in and yes
the foils are hot yeah
is that where the inspiration came from
oh yes it was funny like Kathy Margot
and I all knew exactly what the sound
was meant to look like smell like feel
like and as you know props and people
were bringing us no of course it doesn't
would never be wrapped like that that's
the wrong kind of bread it's the New
York friend you know yes the three of us
were very much in line on the egg
sandwich what was the process like in
finding Harley Quinn's voice for this
movie well you know Christina Hudson our
screenwriter she worked very closely
with the Margo but she has Harley's
voice down I think and that's the thing
that Margo always commented on to that
she just loved how she she could get
into Harley's head and how she realized
that but I think the two of them worked
very closely on that and Margo of
courses she's the Harley expert right
yeah so and she loves the characters so
much so really look at the credit goes
to her very hard work in finding that
voice and it came from a lot of like
homework cuz she you know she we all
read all comics and really immerse
ourselves and Harley Quinn in her
history and then of course all the birds
of prey but but but I think Hudson was
able to kind of turn that into something
that was really unique and and fun did
you guys work closely with Cathy as well
as Margo and crafting Harley hmm well
you know I think everybody worked very
closely together but I think really like
Margo and Kathy worked it on on the
performance I mean Margo you know is
very adapt as figuring out and you know
I thought sets and
scene you know things you know would
evolve from like her process I think she
knows the character better than anybody
and she worked very closely with
Christina she would often call her and
say well what about a line like this or
you know something an expression or
something that was derived from a
situation was a very organic process but
I think I think Margo had her character
down you know better than than any of us
could have yeah you know I really want
to ask you guys about the egg sandwich
because I left craving a breakfast
everybody so it's like people are gonna
just be eating egg sandwiches I think
how did that come about that idea that
was Christina Hudson yeah and then it
was funny in the in the prep process it
was actually difficult to find a bodega
that was you know as greasy and perfect
as as you could as you can find and
sometimes in New York when you're
hungover and you need that exhale which
you know we all had it and we really
wanted to be true to that all experience
it was a lot of fun to make it
yeah there were dozens of versions of
big sandwiches like this right and that
the egg was like flopping around and
right in the right way and the sauce I
mean it was it was very deliberate and
also an artistic undertaking yeah or not
it works yeah I have to ask you guys
what would your thoughts be on a Harley
Quinn margot robbie team up with Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker wow I don't know yeah I
mean they're kind of do you know
existing and two very different well
yeah I think yeah we're right you know
we're still at the place where we're
just trying to launch this this one and
and have been so our husbands so in this
movie in this story and so it is kind of
fun to start thinking about some things
like that but we haven't had any time or
energy into it yet I also think - I I
really love that you know these worlds
are existing very separately in the DC
universe that allows each of the stories
to be told I think in a very singular
way
go the movies benefit from that
[Music]